La comunidad hispana está
alcanzando grandes cotas de influencia
en la economía, la cultura y la
política de los Estados Unidos. Más de
57 millones de personas, casi una de cada
cinco, son hispanos,
dos tercios de ellos originarios de
México. Durante las dos próximas
décadas el crecimiento de esta
comunidad va a tener profundas
implicaciones en la gran potencia
americana y también en el resto de
Latinoamérica. En éste video te
hablamos del poder los hispanos en los
Estados Unidos.
En uno de nuestros últimos vídeos comentamos que
en una fecha tan próxima como 2020 los
hispanos se convertirán en la
población mayoritaria de Texas.
Este no es un fenómeno aislado, de hecho
hoy los hispanos son ya la población
mayoritaria en California y Nuevo
México.
Es decir, en poco más de tres años las
dos mayores economías de Estados Unidos
y casi el 25 por ciento de su producto
interior bruto corresponderán a estados de
mayoría hispana.
- "Bienvenidos a todos en nuestro país
¿verdad? porque somos americanos todos."
¿Os podéis imaginar la enorme influencia
que esto conlleva?
Estamos hablando de estados que en su
conjunto formarían la cuarta mayor
potencia económica de la tierra.
Además, las tasas de crecimiento de los
hispanos, sobre todo por su mayor nivel
de natalidad, son muy importantes: desde el año 2000 en número de hispanos ha
crecido en 20 millones de personas y se
espera que en las tres próximas décadas
dupliquen prácticamente la población
superando la barrera de los 10 millones
de habitantes. Por cierto, la mayoría de
los hispanos hoy han nacido en los
Estados Unidos.
El fenómeno ha sido de tal magnitud que
los inmigrantes latinos que han llegado
a Estados Unidos en los últimos 50 años
superan al conjunto de inmigrantes
llegados de toda Europa entre 1840 y
1920, cuando se produjeron las grandes
migraciones de irlandeses, italianos,
polacos, etcétera ¡Diantres!
Todos conocemos la gran influencia que estas
comunidades tuvieron en la sociedad y en
la historia de Estados Unidos, así que,
ya podemos imaginar la que van a tener
los hispanos, que en menos años han superado
en número a todos ellos. No os quepa la
menor duda de que en poco tiempo veremos
al primer presidente hispano.
- "Hay una comunidad que no merece ser callada, ocultada ni menospreciada. La comunidad
latina le ha dado mucho a Estados Unidos.
Tenemos que seguir así, trabajando,
haciendo un mejor país y soñando con
una mejor nación para todos.
Rocky es el candidato que mejor
representa nuestros valores y nuestro
sentir."
Desde el año 2000 los hispanos han ocupado siete
de cada diez puestos de trabajo creados,
y como son más jóvenes que la media y
han inmigrado, precisamente, para
conseguir una vida mejor, sus tasas de
participación laboral son
sustancialmente mayores que las del
resto de trabajadores.
Esto es, los hispanos trabajan de media
más, lo que evidentemente tiene un impacto
positivo muy grande sobre la actividad
económica de los Estados Unidos.
Por si fuese poco, los hispanos son propietarios
de más de cuatro millones de negocios,
y tienen ¡ojo! las tasas más altas de
emprendimiento, superando incluso a la
población asiática.
La tendencia es tal que la mayoría de
la generación de hispanos
pertenecientes a la denominada
generación millennials afirman que ser
emprendedores y montar empresas es la
mejor forma de prosperar.
- "Como padre me inspira, y como Presidente su valentía me ha hecho recordar que ningún obstáculo
es muy grande,
ningún camino muy largo." ¿Cuál es el
resultado de toda esta pujante actividad?
Pues que los hispanos han incrementado en los últimos cinco años un 50 por
ciento su poder de compra, alcanzando
los 1,5 billones de dólares, es decir el
equivalente a 1,5 veces toda la
economía española. Y esto no es todo, se
espera que para el 2020 alcancen los 2
billones de dólares, por lo que si
formasen su propio país se situarían
entre las diez mayores economías del mundo.
¡Impresionante!
Solo un ejemplo de todo lo que esto
significa: se espera que en los próximos
diez años, en la próxima década, los
hispanos compren en los estados unidos 6
millones de viviendas.
Por cierto, está demostrado, además, que
los inmigrantes favorecen las relaciones
comerciales con sus países de origen, lo
que representa sin duda una oportunidad
única para las empresas
latinoamericanas. En ningún país hispano
hay tanto dinero como el que mueven los
hispanos de Estados Unidos.
- "Una cosa que nunca pensé yo al
principio, cuando vendíamos 50
dolares a la semana, ahora estamos vendiendo millones de dólares.
Algo que empezó casi, casi, sin
querer , hizo que Rudy en pocos años se
convierta de ambulante en todo un
exitoso empresario.
Más de 11 millones de latinos votaron
en 2012 y se espera que para 2030 40
millones de hispanos tengan derecho a
voto. En pocos años los hispanos van a
condicionar no sólo la política de
California, Texas y Nuevo México, donde
van a ser el primer grupo social, sino
que también van a tener una influencia
decisiva en Florida, Nevada, Arizona y
Colorado, donde pronto superarán el 30
por ciento de la población, y también
en Illinois, Nueva York, Connecticut y un
largo etcétera de estados donde
superarán  el 10 por ciento.
De hecho, Greg Abbott, el actual
gobernador de Texas, ya ha dicho que en no
más de dos legislaturas la
supremacía republicana en Texas llegará
a su fin.  - "Los valores que tiene Bernie son los valores de este país, los
valores del trabajar duro, los valores de
la igualdad, los valores de que todos pueden
tener la oportunidad, esos son los
valores americanos."
Hasta ahora la influencia política de
la comunidad ha sido relativamente
pequeña porque buena parte de sus
miembros aún no tienen derecho a voto,
muchos de ellos por cierto simplemente
por no haber pedido la ciudadanía aún
teniendo derecho hacerlos ¡mal!,  o
simplemente por ser menores de edad.
- "que para mañana no sólo usted sino
también su familia
va a estar deportada - ¡De portada? Uy que bonito, y a mí, pero ¿qué es una portada
del hola?...
Además, como en muchos casos los estados donde
viven los hispanos no están en juego su
abstención ha sido tradicionalmente muy
alta. Aún así, en 2008 y en 2012 el voto
latino tuvo una influencia clave en la
elección de Obama y
son ya muchos los analistas que
consideran que es prácticamente
imposible ganar unas elecciones si el
apoyo hispano no es de al menos el 40
por ciento. Además, esta
infraponderación en el poder político
va a cambiar pronto,
y precisamente candidatos como Donald
Trump pueden favorecer decididamente esta
evolución. -"y le quiero decir a Marco
Rubio ponte las pilas,
Jeb Bush ponte las pilas, Hillary Clinton ponte las pilas, porque
Donald Trump no puede ser presidente." Los
republicanos ya cometieron el mismo
error en California, en 1994, cuando el
gobernador Pete Wilson lanzó una dura
política anti inmigración con la vista
puesta en la presidencia. Su iniciativa
conocida como la "Propuesta 187" se
envolvió en una dura retórica anti
hispana y llegaba a negar cualquier
servicio público a los inmigrantes sin
papeles, incluyendo servicios sanitarios
vitales.
Durante la campaña se acusó a los
hispanos de invadir California, delinquir
y quedarse con los puestos de trabajo ¿Os
suena? El resultado es que Wilson ganó y
aprobó la controvertida propuesta, pero
al mismo tiempo aquella campaña despertó
el poder electoral de los latinos: se
crearon redes de influencia, campañas
para animar a votar, plataformas sociales
y desde aquel momento el Partido
Republicano quedó completamente
destruido en el estado. La tierra de
Richard Nixon y Ronald Reagan hoy es
un estado monocolor en favor del Partido
Demócrata.
El caldo de cultivo sembrado por
líderes como Trump es tal que según un
estudio del Pew Research Center el 58
por ciento de los votantes republicanos
consideran que los inmigrantes hispanos son
una amenaza para el futuro de los
Estados Unidos. Esto, además de ser una
falacia, es como querer poner puertas
al mar.
Lo cierto es que de seguir esta tónica
lo pagarán muy caro. - "Yo hablo por toda la
gente mexicana cuando digo que puedes
tomar tus insultos y metertelos
por tu grande y estúpido ***** ¿Que pensáis
vosotros? ¿Creéis que campañas como la
de Trump unirán y movilizarán a más
hispanos?
¿Creéis que pronto veremos al primer
Presidente latino en la Casa Blanca?
Espero que os haya gustado este vídeo,
si ha sido así  no dudéis en
suscribiros al canal, recordad que, como
dice Alberto, es gratis, y mandadnos vuestras
opiniones.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.